au delà de la situation d'un homme il ya
un enjeu qui est la capacité des
journalistes à diffuser des informations
sur qui relèvent du domaine du périmètre
du secret d'état
et c'est un périmètre qui a été étendue
au fil des années et la procédure dont
fait l'objet
je voulais un san jose états unis ces
procédures dites de grand jury elle vise
en fait sa contribution au journalisme
en 2010 elle vise un travail celui de
julian assange qui a permis des
révélations majeures notamment sur les
guerres américaines en irak et en
afghanistan et donc site julian assange
est obligé de comparaître devant les
tribunaux aux états unis s'il devait
être extradé
ça ferait peser une très grande menace
sur le journalisme lui-même lors de
l'une des premières apparitions de
julian devant la cour le juge a demandé
à julian son nom et sa date de naissance
il était dans de telles conditions qu'il
ne s'en rappelait même pas c'est très
inhabituel de continuer d'écouter la
plaidoirie d'un prisonnier
quand il ne peut même pas se souvenir de
sa date de naissance ou de son plein
nous pensions alors que julian serait
immédiatement envoyé à l'hôpital pour
recevoir des soins
c'est ce qui se serait passé en
australie
le juge n'aurait pas continué à l'écouté
dans ces conditions